I did see a killer whale show you know
what they did the the killer whale show
there was like three of them right
smaller it wasn't even like the big ones
they were smaller they came up and then
they did this
and it was like yeah
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
careful boys today we have everybody
here
[Applause]
so we were just talking about what we
should do for another JK adventure and
Anthony said red and so it's fair and I
highly agree I think we should go to the
Renaissance Fair I've never been me
neither my God I went I never had that
that was the most gangster sixth grade
field trips ever so what do you when you
go to a Renaissance Fair what's like
what's the first on the docket what do
you do do you tell do you tell everyone
me Lord and me lady
that's beer this is my favorite part
because I see it in all the posters it's
when the titties get pushed up here
and they got giant pickles in between
put them on the glass put them on the
glass so one of them isn't the
Oktoberfest no that's just German but
they got the boobies too you know they
have the boobies up against the top of
the boobies completely different event
also with good boobies though I could
see it's boobie adjacent though everyone
is role playing a time in which men were
in charge so we can actually walk up to
checks and say take them out
dude so there's tons of different like
little shows there's like jousting
there's ax throwing Spirit throwing
knife throwing every like throwing you
could think of yeah crazy like for you
kind of like Medieval Times kind of food
like big ass turkey legs I love turkey
legs yeah only at events like that I
wouldn't like that because I'd be like
that's not Renaissance that's medieval
that's medieval
we might want to go on a date Joe's not
available
Italy
that's where it was killing it the most
yeah yeah that's where it was like
slamming no yeah I think it happened a
lot of Europe in general I think
Renaissance is much more of like a human
experience
yeah
is it not like Italy had it and then we
what was the Renaissance this is like
[__] C students talking about history
it's like people picking up uh Jurassic
Park and saying that's not the Jurassic
art and like music and culture was
starting to stop that's when the Ninja
Turtles came out though Michelangelo
Leonardo they're all [__] like Casey
Jones did China contribute to the
Renaissance dude don't ask me about
China That's why Jackson's not here let
me do it the [__] Indonesia
contribute to the Renaissance you mean
where the hot guys are yeah so what
about Druids will we find some Druids
it's on site no yeah there are Druids
yeah what the [__] is a druid the
cultural artistic political and economic
rebirth in Europe referred to as the
Renaissance occurred during the 14th and
17th century
still say Europe it's like I'm at the
ren fair right now thank you but what
did they what did Portugal do in the
Renaissance what the [__] are you asking
about Portugal redfair is pretty fun
big question because this isn't like
[__] San Dimas or something hey what
do you guys think the Portuguese were
doing back then why are you asking us
like we got the answer wait what kind of
Nick question are you doing right now
the Portuguese were the first one of the
first to colonize Portuguese the
Renaissance Fair is is in the Santa Fe
Dam which is really cool because you
can't see the freeway or anything
yeah you really feel like you're in the
Renaissance yeah so what can can you
like throw axes or something yeah that's
literally what he said at the beginning
of the video dude there's like five
different throwing events I've never
thrown an ax before do you love it
that's right though it might start in
Florence Italy
they're the ones that guys that started
it yeah
because you only hear about the
Italiano's it's true you kind of know
your stuff actually I'm really glad we
brought that up because like now it's
like opening my mind yeah it's good
content
we got to go there questioning everybody
hey are you Portuguese Renaissance are
you like OG Italian Renaissance because
if everyone got British accents
Italian because they're the ones that
did it and so if they have a British
accent you got to call them out and be
like shouldn't you be no but it's like
the Renaissance Fair it's like the world
fair like different people from
different areas and ages of the
Renaissance but they're not part of the
[__] well neither were you nope
but I'm not dressed up with my titties
you watch a American movie like someone
that's like a bad guy or whatever they
might be like Arab but they have a
British accent I do like that it's
pretty funny sophisticated British if
you have a if you have a cell phone next
to your head and you talk in British
accent you're probably an epic bad guy
um wow yeah that looks cool or you're
like a double o seven yeah good side
area what other Adventures would you
guys want to do well I want to milk a
sheep that's cool a Renaissance right
don't they dream don't they drink Sheep
No back then they got [__] goat
cheese and [__] could you is that one of
the activities we can do at The Rim I
think you can I think there's like cows
and there's different like I don't know
if you can milk them I think they'll
show you yeah you might be able to watch
a blacksmith do something or watch
somebody turn butter that's pretty cool
I want to see it they do have people
simulating blacksmithing too I don't
know if they're actually that's all
medieval [__] man they're just standing
there they're playing the cowbell pretty
much yeah I think we're making [__] up
because Renaissance yeah Renaissance
were more refined yeah but they still
had blacksmiths during that time it went
from horseshoes to now [__] scope
when does the Civil War start during
this
if there's a blacksmith going like this
and going Milan your sword is almost
ready
if you're gonna worry about that you
might as well be like how come you have
a cell phone and welcome to everybody
who's working excuse me my Lord we're
here for the Civil War reenactment we're
pointing Us in the direction what do you
need your parking validation
this isn't Renaissance culture there's
no parking I don't even think they have
turkeys in Europe dude that's an
American bird would you guys show it you
may just have to take it up with the
fair when we get there I'll be like
where's the Pheasant where's the
turducken all right where's the [__]
ducking he's like they don't have turkey
out there but they got turducken
would you guys show up to the Civil War
reenactment in full
um Confederate regalia with me yeah I'm
down wow I think you would really look
the part I think we'd really look
confused I think so but I'm only going
as a southern Rebel so yeah exactly we
have to is there an Asian equivalent to
the Civil War reenactment they like do
it over
civil Warrior well in Japan
but do Japanese people reenact it they
reenact um Samurai [__] maybe there's
things there's like Vietnam there oh my
God are those things like the Korean War
enactment like that no they do uh they
do like those shows where people that
are hardcore enthusiasts yeah like it's
kind of like LARPing yeah but then it's
sick because
you go to these events and rich people
that like get into it they'll have
horses and then they'll just be riding
down the horses and [__] shooting
arrows out the side and then they'll be
doing targets you talk about pilgrims
and engines see that's why I want to go
as a Confederate because you can talk
like that the whole [__] time okay I
want to join you if you go as the knob
I'm not gonna get canceled right but
yeah you know not in there you know the
more stay on your end of the street
please with all that [__]
yeah just be that character that's such
a good part wow that was crazy good
thank you I think we should still go to
wrestling show yes hey dude let's go to
WrestleMania I could go to a wrestle
show every week 40 bucks what yeah that
ticket's 40 bucks is it like we don't
know like the sofas dude you know what I
mean we don't know like Sofi oh dude you
want to park at sofa it's like eight
grand dude but Sofi has kind of worth it
though that how close can we be with
forty dollars though is that nosebleeds
we'll be bleeding we'll be bleeding
first we gotta be aware like we might
get on camera
no the energy of that kind of stuff has
to be close yeah how much is it to get
at the front where we can be on camera
and the chair might hit us yeah oh yeah
I mean that's G gcw you'll get that for
gcw we can get in the ring 45 bucks I
want the sweat of them dripping on me
with the blood that would be that okay
pro wrestling we have red
Sea World
see oh I used to love I've never been
you never been we've been in the Golden
Era of [__] animal exploitation
there's no more Shamu there's no more uh
that was that was the best show they cut
a lot of shows that's like when they
pulled Michael uh Jordan out of the
Bulls like that's Shamu was the [__]
[__] bro
yeah they they stopped doing a mess like
[__] performances and they kind of have
a more educational like things last time
like demos but they don't make them do
tricks like they used to last time I
went was like 2012 or some [__] right I
went there and I was like what the [__]
is this this is not my childhood where
the [__] is the trainer on top of the
Shamu nose flying into the air flipping
like five times and then shampoo goes
like this and you want to be in the
front because Shamu [__] slams the
water and [__] hits you like a
[__] those particular ones they
got like eating and stuff that was my
question the trainer got eaten not all
of them they got drowned they got they
got held down and like drowned out yeah
dude I remember all of them they got
dolphins in there with [__] traffic
cones on their nose and [__] taking
that [__] up you watch traffic drop back
down floating service than the Dolphins
were dragging it around and [__] they'll
let you [__] pet their tongues and
stuff yeah that's so sick man the
goldness octopus just spin up they light
a hoop on fire
windmill when I did see a killer whale
show you know what they did the the
killer whale show there was like three
of them right smaller it wasn't even
like the big ones they were smaller they
came up and then they did this
and then it was like yeah that was
better than my Bart impersonation
because dude that fool just went up like
on you know how they have the platforms
right yeah they do this and then they go
how do they know that they weren't
having a [__] blast because I see
that and I'm like they're having a riot
of a time yeah because their dorsal fin
turned into a freaking turn into bangs
yeah it was like a like a Ed type of
thing you know do we know that's why
well the other thing that they don't do
anymore is they used to get the fin the
the Shamu used to get a Fin and he would
splash water on you and then you'll be
like oh no
no they don't do that anymore all right
well hey what if we do what if we do a
JK Adventure where we shoot guns nah
that's too gays nah like real guns I got
real people I'm not real people but why
do you want to shoot guns for I think
it'd be fun what was wrong with airsoft
that was cool that was cool but I feel
like that's your guys's domain and you
guys could like we used to do it all the
time but then like YouTube [__]
Shadow bands those videos and like uh
yeah it's not it's not good you could
shoot guns for fun yeah we could do that
yeah but Nick won't show up let's go
let's go to Sea World and we can just
tell Nick how awesome it used to be the
whole time we're there I'll be like oh
cool imagine this but check this out dog
it's like balloons balls as far as the
eye can see dolphins flipping through
the air now you're like you know it's
kind of like what it used to be like
it's kind of like the pyramids but this
is what it really was we just like hold
up photos of like the Glory Days in the
same spot
that's cool it's where you use the surf
walruses okay so Sea World is on the
list on the bottom tier barely on the
list
um you know those things that I always
wanted to see I always saw it during
cartoons right there was the circus the
PT Barnum I went to that see I didn't
get to go to that you didn't see the
elephants on the balls did you get to go
to Santa's village yeah and I still go
there
what do you mean why
because a mountain it's a mountain
biking Park oh that's so good here's a
bad idea in the summer we go to a water
park together dude let's go to water
park that's disgusting I know I know it
is but when we were kids it wasn't
disgusting nothing's changing you
actually go to one because I'm a dad now
which one it's called Cowabunga Bay
cowboy in Vegas there's a water park
there yeah it's called can you even fit
in the tube what do you mean yeah you
got [__] stuck right away dude like
18 workers have to jump on things don't
push you through it's actually pretty
fun routing City water into that thing
yeah it's called cow Bunga Bay it's not
in Vegas
is it pretty crowded
uh it's just like any bunch of Raging
Waters it's probably let's go dude
there's 39 degrees yesterday I'm just
saying that [__] is dirty as it is that
[__] was so fun you've never been to a
water park ever do you have a childhood
have you ever had pink eye you just been
grappling since birth that's why
I never been to a water park either make
a joke it's fun my parents were like we
live next to a ocean like that's your
water park well they make it they make
it in a way where you can have more fun
in the water and you don't even know how
need to know how to swim that's cool I
think that was their excuse to not pay
because you go down slides and then the
water you land in is like this so you go
you can like turn the bucket when it's
full of water on a bunch of kids
understanding they just have them drown
it's like when they say we have
McDonald's at home yeah that's literally
what happened and I didn't even live
next to a beach it was still 20 minutes
away
it's like you got [__] Redondo you
got Torrance and then you got Gardena it
would be called Gardena Beach
they're like we're next to water the
only thing I don't like are the fake
beaches at the water park you don't like
those damn we're drowning together and
[__] oh you mean the man-made ones that
but the waves oh let's go let's all go
hang out and then the [__] waves come
and it's like a bunch but not paying
attention and everyone gets submerged at
the same time because they're all
[__] you know like I like it when
when it's body to body and there's not
even any blue water around you and
you're just stuck next to everybody and
everyone's pissing
to do us those surfing that looks fun
indoor surfing yeah like like those
man-made waves that's a really good
activity that's a good activity I would
love to break my leg with you guys [__]
those look so fun we just opened one in
Hawaii really but yeah that's crazy
just for that it's
what's the one that's off in like Roland
Heights that has like slick tracks I
think it's also K1 right oh that one uh
at the mall I don't know if they're even
open anymore we got super cars off of
the 15. the top supercars like the
speedway we could we could race cars wow
like a Lambo and then drive around we
can get like his Mazda Miata out there
dude I'll bring the Miata my boy I can
drive a stick can we squeak your tires
up
as it sold but you know I know how to
drive a Miana do you still want to go
bungee jumping I never said that you
didn't you see recently at the [__]
Court snap I know what a thrill too many
of those videos
so that [__] I'd rather Skydive me too I
saw one were the skydiver he was [__]
getting caught in his parachute and it
was like
and at the last moment he pulled out
that emergency one and that was getting
caught and he had to undo it so it could
fly out and then he got it just in the
moment it was [__] wild I was like
wow that was intense one of my clients
told me um his his friend's dad was a um
skydiving instructor yeah and he had a
stroke in in one of his jumps no [__]
way he had a stroke or his like during
the jump yeah he was doing by himself
did he survive so what about all the
students
I don't know I don't know
I'm not done with
my buddy went hypoxic up there like when
he was just about to jump what's that
mean it's like you something happens
with your lungs yeah and you can't
breathe and then he like was passing out
and like laying on the floor in the
plane like they had to like go land and
[__] it was wild yeah this this video
took a turn for the dark side but that's
why we can't do that [__] dude no we
should do it I mean statistically we'll
be we'll be okay yeah I think I'm still
fine on skydiving laser tag there's a
lot of stuff after I became a dad that I
was like I should probably try to stay
alive I think that's why laser tags well
dude I got it we should just do a police
ride along all of us in the back seat
they're gonna have to get like a big bus
for us you don't like those
can we do that that'll be fine I wish we
knew some SWAT guys to get in like an
armored car in the back of it do you not
know SWAT guys you're useless
what guy DM me doesn't matter what the
actually I do know a SWAT guy see I'll
hit him up but he's in Chicago
Chicago that's long that's far I mean if
he flies
this guy got that thickest
[__] IG reels because you know when
you're when you're when you work uh in a
city that has a body of water their
police tactics is way cooler so a lot
some of his [__] is just him hanging off
a helicopter with [__] dangly feet
and then [__] just the uh like Lake
Ontario or whatever underneath them
like cool [__] like like [__] like a
bad boy [__] because you know like
they're police but because of the ocean
and whatever it's just it's way
different than policing and it's not
like our national security yeah they got
they got cool terrain they got crazy
late cups they got cops they got those
[__] Navy SEAL type raft boats but
they're police officers because they
gotta Patrol the lakes and [__] dude
yeah but it's cool Coast Guard hey you
guys just had me at Lake there's lakes
in Vegas right we do like a lake
situations how does it like mean
you said that's so not fun yeah I really
made it sound boring
Las Vegas remember that place we went to
that river that connects to Lake me
like me those people that
people that [__] ass dude yeah yeah I
was like what did how do you go so Vegas
SWAT guys or Lake Mead officers DM me
please not even officers can we just
party it like
just get a regular book I know right
there's got to be some activity it's
like when he's a party I've got to get a
houseboat you know those houseboats it's
like a two-story boat and then you get
to like you could really watch TV that's
almost anybody here gets seasick no yeah
I do but I'll Dramamine it up this time
ginger ale you get seasick on a lake but
it's not C well no the rocking of the
boat is what it doesn't rock that hard
you should Joe you should tell people
who gets seasick that it's not the scene
and drama means for drama you're just
being a drama queen right now basically
it's like a waterbed the lake is like
doesn't even blow are you guys down to
go golfing yeah we've been golfing with
you so many times we went to the driving
range oh
are we gonna piss everyone off because
how long no that's why we're gonna do
the night golfing at Monterey Park it's
only nine holes in part three we can't
even film that [__] it's all dark yeah
dark as [__] what about during the day
but what about we go okay we go early
and then we come here what else you got
I'll shoot it down why don't we go to
Vegas
and then we don't have to go to one that
speaks I'm not gonna go to 18 hole Par
Four with you guys and just be chasing
balls in the woods the whole time for
five hours why not
with you guys in Vegas
in Vegas yeah there's 7 000 golf courses
there significantly more expensive out
there and is it and you do have to like
like everybody's got to be good on like
timing because oh my friend lives on a
golf course we'll just go to his [__]
backyard open the gate and we can start
playing we're going to do that as free
f-r-e-e not the same as a game but okay
whoa okay are we sure it's free
is it like a train where you go in and
you sit down and then you think it's
free and then the conductor comes and
goes where's your ticket
we do have the homie hookup right here
the Monterey Park they're they're gonna
hook us up with good food too do they
still got monster truck rallies yes oh
yeah I want to go I went I went to
Monster Jam a few a few years ago all
these things I wanted to do as a kid we
gotta do Mr Jam's super fun I went to a
monster truck show like in San Diego but
it wasn't the monster truck show like
with bigfooting Gravedigger oh we gotta
see that [__] now they got it uh they
got one called son of a Gravedigger wow
that's just like it's like literally
like a junior Gravedigger but that's
just as good what happened to
Gravedigger he's still there but it's
like a hasbula version no it's it's not
in smaller it's just like a new
generation and that dude is actually a
really good driver yeah let's go see
let's go see that
don't forget to add Shin Lim to the list
well because what happened was Bigfoot
Bigfoot got too famous and started
showing up in movies and TV remember
that Bigfoot and then so there was a
licensing uh thing where he wanted more
money to come back to Monster Jam and
he's like we ain't doing it yeah so
Bigfoot left but there's Gravedigger
there's all kinds of things he thought
he was so Good by himself he's like a
boy band guy and he tried to make it on
his own and it's like it's the industry
bro it's not just you exactly it's also
add the prices right to the list price
is right I've never been let's go dude
dude I've never been either to wait in
line or anything let's go I came close
to going because I got my buddy that for
a wrap party gift because I was at this
like kitten ball and they're like you
can get on The Price is Right with Drew
Carey and I was like my friend will
think this sucks this is a great gift
dude if I get chosen I'm gonna react
like a Filipino mom dude like it's gonna
be nuts I'm gonna get hysterical and
start crying simple and go to a Ken just
practice and we all try to learn a
routine too everybody's waiting for that
like desperately we should hold off yeah
we should hold off right here's here's
the problem that we're all that I'm
worried about is like once we do that
you guys are gonna ask me to be a Kinja
yeah he doesn't have time for that dude
just like we don't have time for the
rest of this video I think we gotta move
on now dude we should do training with
Nick
we can't shoot at night sorry that shot
down we're flying to Hawaii
foreign